yeah no I'm not I'm not I'm not shocked
um I mean he controls a huge percentage
of the Republican party I mean the
Republic Republicans in America support
Donald Trump if they were the only
voters he would be president
um again easily
um they're afraid of him he also wields
power in a way
that no recent president has I mean I
mean Mitt Romney pushed back he went on
Twitter attacked him attacked him
publicly this is a this is a different
animal to me there's a lot
put aside the differences of which there
are some
um in the level of the alleged offense
between this and Watergate the climate
is remarkably different I mean think of
Watergate Howard Baker
a moderate United States senator who
made it clear to the world that in his
mind his legacy was more important than
Richard Richard Nixon's immediate
survival there were there were more
Republican Senators like that first off
there was no Fox News yes I always I I
have this um I'm not I'm not a um
literary writer or play playwright but I
always thought if there is one in the
room my wife's a writer but if there's
one in the room someone in the room who
um who can imagine picture Watergate
with Fox News picture Watergate what
imagine what that would have been like
John Dean's remarkable testimony a
nation riveted by the story
and then Sean Hannity
comes on at night and says look at that
little twerp
wasn't he awful he's been against us
from the very beginning he's betraying
us it would have been a very different
story there were three television
networks
there were Republicans and as I said who
were moderate and that this climate is
very different but here's what we don't
know I don't know I think we didn't know
what Trump and would Donald with the
president and Rudy Giuliani had done in
the Ukraine to this extent a few months
ago
I don't think I don't know what we're
going to know in
two months I don't know I don't know
what the level of of what the where the
level of allegations will go I don't I
don't know the answer to that and that's
a big unknown and I don't know whether
it arrives the Iowa caucuses are in
February I don't know whether it arrives
before the Iowa caucuses half the
candidates are United States senators
who would have to fly back to vote the
period between now and the middle of
next year will be one of the most stay
tuned will be one of the most dramatic
periods in American politics an
impeachment hearing an election half the
candidates getting to vote it's going to
be stunning
[Music]
um
very interesting and again dispiriting I
think has been I was talking to my wife
who was watching a bit
um and
um it's extraordinary that the kind of
there was a kind of scuttlebut around I
don't know where really on the web that
and I think it was true some of you here
may have noticed this and there was a
British complaint that oh dear for these
hearings are so dull they quote I picked
up on Twitter Lac Pizzazz now that is of
course you know the pizzazz shortage is
you're all right I I laugh too but
actually there is a serious issue in the
issue in my understanding is this is
that Donald Trump did actually whether
it was Donald Trump or Steve Bannon but
I think it was really it came naturally
to Donald Trump as a TV reality show
presenter that he realized
um at the time the rallies were going on
and sober Minds including me in so far
as my mind is over sober said well these
are ephemeral things my son-in-law works
on the Hillary Clinton campaign and he
certainly said rally Ishmael is
basically what counts as our algorithmic
calculations about who who we've got and
who we haven't and big decisions about
where you put your advertising budget
actually depended on what those
algorithms told you and they told you
Wisconsin's going to be fine Michigan's
going to be fine what Donald Trump
discovered was the Glee of hatred was
this extraordinary way in which you
could sort of transcribe transpose
really the sort of the visceral
aggression the adrenaline rush of taking
on enemies the hit of brutal rudeness
which is his bread and butter on The
Apprentice and actually turn it into
Political capital
so the issue you you run an institution
about the thinks again when you're
talking so eloquently about the
difference of 1974 and Fox News not
being there you know fixtures like David
Brinkley and York Pippa The Washington
Post and so on they were sort of like
political Church they were sort of
accepted as you know reliably
transparent and so on and now the hits
which means where advertisers are going
to put their money is on the rush of
celebrity wildness almost it's almost
almost like that so the the the worrying
thing is actually the kind of the
intoxication of hatred is such an
extraordinary issue in American public
how does something as serious and
judicious
um as the New York Times deal with that
I'm not asking you to turn yourself into
a kind of Cabaret of liberal Joy or
something or on the other hand it's not
a bad idea
um but do you think you know how do you
fight back again against that because
that's what Hannity and and Coulter and
Laura Ingraham that's what they do is
what Russian inboard does Rush Limbaugh
is a great Entertainer alas yeah so you
you very eloquently
captured the issue
um and it's it's really difficult I mean
I can tell you what weapons I think we
have
I I can tell you my honest belief is
that over time we win
um because to be frank over time we
usually win I don't mean the Press but I
mean the the press the fact based
independent press has won every time I
mean Richard Nixon attacked the
Washington Post relentlessly everybody
forgets how long Watergate lasted it
lasted like two years The Washington
Post was all by itself banging away
Richard Nixon threatened their
television licenses it did not now it
looks like oh my God it was the Nirvana
of Journalism at the time in the moment
it looked like one newspaper
sloppily I mean it wasn't sloppy I'm
just saying what the perception was
sloppily pushing against the tide it
took the long time for the New York
Times and other news organizations to
jump in to the phrase so my my own view
is that I think you I think we win if
that's the right way to put it by
continuing to be independent
continuing to dig continuing to report
going out in the country and talking to
people who don't just live in New York
or Los Angeles or San Francisco
getting talking to we what we failed to
do in 2016 by the way is not doing
enough for that I think the the anger
the the sense of Abandonment that you
described that a lot of Americans felt
that led is one of the reasons Donald
Trump won one of the reasons that
Americans wanted something dramatically
different I don't think we had a handle
on I don't think we quite understood The
Hangover from the the financial crisis I
don't think we quite had our heads
around the you know the the effects of
real income inequality in the sense that
a lot of people felt that the rich got
fixed after the economic crisis and they
didn't I don't think we had a handle on
how much people were upset by the
arrival of Technology the death of the
industries they worked in and I think
that the sum of the elite press to be
frank
look down on those people a little bit
and and and didn't go out and say trust
me net I mean we we gave them the
impression even the American Presidents
trust us NAFTA is going to be good for
you I think if I I believe and this is
my naive part if we go out into the
world talk to those people understand
them write about them explain the world
to them and do it relentlessly for years
which is essentially what happened with
Watergate I think in that case I'm gonna
I'm gonna believe that truth wins out I
have to